Muttertag die größte kapitalistische
Erfindung seit es print on demand Poster
Fidget Spinner und Socken mit dem
eigenen Gesicht drauf gibt jedes Jahr
werden in Deutschland alleine über 900
Millionen Euro nur für
Muttertagsgeschenke ausgegeben und nur
an Valentinstag und Weihnachten geht
mehr Kohle über den Tisch und ihr wisst
wo Geld schlummert bin ich nicht weit
aber lieber Mamas wir machen das alles
nur für euch und ein bisschen für den
Porsche ob das funktioniert was wir
genau Vorhaben und warum nicht dieser
Ton ziemlich glücklich macht erfahrt ihr
in dieser Folge von Porsche Trader ich
wünsche euch viel Spaß
und bevor das Video jetzt losgeht
vergesst nicht den Kanal zu abonnieren
wenn euch dieses Video gefällt und ihr
kommende Videos nicht verpassen wollt
vielen Dank für euren Support vielleicht
schaffen wir es ja bald zu Millionen
schauen wir uns als erstes an welche
Muttertagsgeschenke am meisten
verschenkt werden und dadurch auch im
Zweifelsfall den meisten Umsatz machen
auf Platz 3 mit knapp 35% ist
Gastronomie mit der Mutter essen gehen
sie zum Essen einladen Essen bestellen
was auch immer Platz zwei mit 48 %
Lebensmittel geschenkt also Schokolade
Pralinen auch sehr beliebt aber noch
lange nicht so beliebt wie Platz 1 ihr
habt es schon vermutet die Blumen gehört
in jedes feste Repertoir eines guten
muttertagsgeschenkes und damit auch in
diese Folge von Porsche Trailer unser
Ziel ist also klar Punkt eins Blumen
günstig einkaufen Punkt zwei einen Ort
finden an dem wir die Blumen möglichst
einfach und möglichst häufig verkaufen
können und Punkt 3 verkaufen verkaufen
verkaufen und die Mütter dieser Welt
glücklich machen plötzlich kam mir die
Idee gegenüber von unserem alten Büro
gab es einen Blumenladen mit einem
Besitzer der unheimlich nett war wir
haben ihm geholfen er hat uns geholfen
und so weiter so kommt es dass er mir
noch einen kleinen Gefallen schuldet ich
habe ihn also angerufen und um Hilfe
gewesen
guten Tag moin Dave 4 dein ehemaliger
Nachbar
nur etwas Überzeugungsarbeit hat Richie
dann tatsächlich zugestimmt und zu
helfen
ja cool das ist genau was ich mir
vorgestellt habe es ist hammergeil weil
Richie ist die absolute Legende und ich
hoffe der kann uns gute Preise
organisieren wir können über den jetzt
wahrscheinlich dann die Blumen beziehen
und finden Maxi Male Mare rausholen
let's go mit richtig zum Blumenkohl
hallo und herzlich Willkommen Blum
Wesseling eurem blumengroßhandel in Köln
wir haben 6 Uhr morgens deswegen seht es
mir nachher nicht nicht ganz auf der
Höhe bin aber auf dem Großmarkt geht es
nun mal früher los und weil es hier im
Großhandel so eine vielfältige Auswahl
gibt haben wir sofort die richtigen
Blumen für unsere Streusel gefunden ein
Traum und sind mit ihnen zu wünschen in
den Laden gefahren ich bin also um 6 Uhr
morgens aus dem Bett gefallen und zum
Großhandel zu fahren gestern war einer
der allerersten wirklich warmen Tage
wieder in Köln und ihr stimmt mir
bestimmt zu wenn ich sage wir haben es
vermisst was wir aber nicht vermisst
haben sind die Ultra warm Nächte in
denen man sich von links nach rechts
wälzt und einfach kein Auge zu bekommen
weil es viel zu warm ist gerade im
Sommer schwitzt man ca einen Liter pro
Nacht in unsere Matratze aber genau
damit ist jetzt Schluss danke das
Partner des heutigen Videos immer der
immer Premium Topper verteilt nämlich
dank seines kühlenden Diamond the
greenshows auch überschüssige
Körperwärme und befreit euch von
unnötiger Hitze beim Schlafen bedeutet
es ist weniger heiß und ich schlafe dazu
auch noch wie im Hotel weil er eine
Komfort von 9 cm im wahrsten Sinne des
Wortes und top bekommen und das Problem
des Kopfkissen auf die kühle Seite
drehen zu müssen damit ihr irgendwie ein
Schlaf kommt das ist dank des
premiumflauschkissens auch nicht mehr
nötig dieses Kissen überträgt nämlich
die gesamte Abwärme von eurem Körper auf
das Thermomaterial was einen sicheren
trockenen und vor allem kühlen Schlaf
garantiert aber auch neben diesen beiden
Produkten gibt es ein Riesensortiment an
Produkten die euren Schlaf verbessern
also von gesamten Boxspringbetten
überlappenroste bis hin zu
matratzentopern Kissen Decken und so
weiter jeder wird bei immer fündig um
seinen Schlaf zu verbessern ich selber
schlafe auf einer ma 25 Hybrid bin
gerade auf den Premium Topper und auf
das Premium flauschkissen umgestiegen
und kann es nur wärmstens empfehlen noch
bis zum 16.06 sind unheimlich viele
Produkte im Emmersdorf um bis zu 40 %
reduziert und wem das noch nicht reicht
mit dem Kunden Blumenladen spart ihr
extra 5% auch auf bereits reduzierte war
also klickt auf den ersten Link in der
Videobeschreibung macht euch ready für
den Sommer und wechselt zu einem
kühlenden entspannten Schlaf vielen Dank
immer für die Unterstützung dieses
Videos vergesst nicht den Code
Blumenladen für 5 % extra zu benutzen
und viel Spaß weiter mit dem Video
welcome to the show der Hauptgrund warum
wir aber jetzt genau hier stehen und
Richies Hilfe benötigen ist weil wir
teststreuse binden müssen weil wir
gucken müssen zu welchem Preis bieten
wir welche Sträuße an machen wir
verschiedene Sträuße in verschiedenen
Farben machen wir verschiedene
Preiskategorien und genau das machen wir
jetzt wir haben also herum
experimentiert was das Zeug hält um die
richtigen Kombination aus Blumen für
unseren Verkauf zu finden und auch ich
durfte mich mal versuchen zum Entsetzen
von Richie
aber schlussendlich hatten wir drei
fertige Sträuße in drei Preiskategorien
die Sträuße haben wir dann mit in unser
Büro genommen um sie zu fotografieren
und genau jetzt kommen wir zum
Knackpunkt meiner Idee wir wollen keinen
Laden anmieten wo die Leute zu uns
kommen müssen um die Blumen zu kaufen
das gibt's ja schon also machen wir
einen Blumenhandel über Volt eine
führende liefer-app hier in Köln auf
dass die Leute ganz bequem übers Handy
ihre Blumen bestellen wir brauchen
keinen Laden wir müssen nichts
repräsentatives haben und die Blumen
werden abgeholt und zu den Leuten
hingebracht und nur wenn wir wollen was
wir langfristig wollten fahren wir die
Blumen selber aus dazu aber später mehr
also Fotos gemacht und damit war
basically alles geschafft außer ein
wirklicher Anreiz bei uns zu kaufen und
deswegen haben wir Muttertags Specials
gemacht werden Wein eingekauft wir haben
Karten selber Design und bestellt und
eben die Straße die wir zum Muttertags
bündeln zusammengepackt haben dass man
sie insgesamt als perfektes rundes Paket
für seine Mutter bestellen kann und das
meine lieben Freunde sollte sich als
sehr gute Idee herausstellen es ist so
weit unsere Lieferung ist da die Blumen
kommen das heißt wir können mit dem
Verkauf starten den Shop online schalten
und umsetzen da kommt der Master auf
dieser Welt
[Musik]
schwöre bester Mann wir haben zehn Mal
die günstigen Streusel 10 mal die
mittleren Streusel und zehnmal die
teuren Streusel dass sie sind die
Fotomodelle die werden wir aber
natürlich auch noch mit verkaufen sechs
Mal Rotwein sechs Mal Weißwein fünf mal
sechs und die werden in Bundles verkauft
unsere selbst designten muttertagskarten
jetzt heißt es
Geld verdienen ich habe vor einigen
Minuten Shop live gestellt und jetzt
kannst im Prinzip
oder
okay wir brauchen Set aus Weißwein das
ist da dann ein kleiner Strauß Bilder
das ist ja komplett geil
mega krank und die Sets haben direkt
funktioniert
[Musik]
oder verpassen keine order verpasst
danke
[Musik]
schon wieder
oh mein Gott Digger es funktioniert
[Musik]
mit
order
confirmes ready for delivery
wir legen die Blumen einfach hierhin
warten auf den Kurier der holt die ab
wir werden ein Stück reicher kommen den
Porsche einen Schritt näher und so
verrücktes klingt auch Laufkundschaft
ist auf unseren Laden aufmerksam
geworden und das völlig durch Zufall es
sind Leute reingekommen und haben Blumen
gekauft das ja cool
vielen dank danke sehr gut
ist klar
[Musik]
sorry ich musste noch erstmal Rewe
kaufen damit die das teurer aus Gold
kaufen dann neue Bestellung vielen Dank
danke
es läuft gut unseres Gefühls nach ein
bisschen zu gut wir haben nur noch einen
kleinen Strauß wir haben vier mittlere
vier große und ein bisschen Wein ich
denke das ist Zeit ist Richie anzurufen
und Streusel nachzubestellen also gerade
sind drei orders die wirklich groß sind
zweimal kleine Strolche in einer Order
zweimal mittlere mit Karte und einmal
ein großer Strauß mit Karte und ein
kleiner innerhalb von wirklich 4 Minuten
reingekommen und es ist glaube ich Zeit
Richie zu fragen ob er uns aushelfen
kann hallöchen äh bist du im Laden habt
ihr Kapazitäten
vielleicht mal so fünf kleine und drei
mittlerer ja bis gleich sag mir Bescheid
wenn du fertig bist sofort
[Musik]
Richie und genau in diesem Moment haben
wir gerade die letzten beiden kleinen
Sträuße verkauft und ein mittleren und
zwei große haben wir noch die anderen
stehen da schon ready zur Abholung also
wieder drei order das gleichzeitig und
wir machen uns direkt auf den Weg holen
die neue Ware von Richie weil der Laden
ist noch zwei Stunden offen hallo
[Musik]
die Situation spitzt sich zu 20 Minuten
ist der Shop noch offen und 20 Minuten
haben jetzt die Leute auch nur noch Zeit
wirklich zu bestellen also besser geht's
nicht 110 ja genau jawohl soll ich
mitnehmen
[Gelächter]
wird der letzte Blumenstrauß für heute
abgeliefert was geht
ihr beiden okay genau da läuft unsere
letzte Bestellung von Tag eins in den
Sonnenuntergang ich hoffe es zu ich
würde ihn am liebsten noch drei Stunden
weiterlaufen lassen ähm komplett
geisteskrank ich glaube 35 oder 36
Blumensträuße jetzt verkauft und morgen
geht's nur noch krasser Endabrechnung
kommt dann am Ende von Tag 2 also morgen
Abend nicht nur wie viel Umsatz sondern
vor allem wie viel Gewinn gemacht haben
wie weit wir noch vom Porsche entfernt
sind aber so entspannt sollte es nicht
bleiben es gibt ein Problem sonntags
liefert wollten nicht sie haben keine
eigenen Fahrer die Sonntags fahren
sondern man ist selber darauf angewiesen
dass Essen die Blumen egal was man über
die Plattform verkauft selber zum Kunden
zu bringen wenn man sonntags verkaufen
möchte das hieß also wir müssen uns
selber unsere Helme anziehen und die
Blumen selber zu den Kunden bringen ja
Tag Nummer zwei
mit dem Roller mit dem Fahrrad mit dem
Auto die ersten Bestellung sind schon
drin der Shop ist noch nicht mal offen
aber es wird vorbestellt und wir fangen
jetzt einfach schon ab zu arbeiten weil
wir Schiss haben dass es zu viel wird
ja wunderbar
geht los Leo und ich fahren kein Problem
Honda 110 Kubik 4 Gang Halbautomatik
jetzt werden Mittagessen Transport
[Musik]
viel Spaß oh vielen Dank danke Ciao
komplett vergessen jetzt gibt's ja auch
noch Trinkgeld ab zum zweiten auftragen
wenn du das siehst
[Musik]
bitte sehr Ciao
kein Trinkgeld heute stellen wir eine
Statistik auf wie viel Trinkgeld und wie
viel nicht eins von drei Bestellungen
nur Trinkgeld
du Mix Mittel den können wir aktuell
nicht liefern
können mittleren Strauß aber wir haben
kein mittleren Straße
muss nur noch fünf kleine machen und
dann kommt der jetzt ist schon
problematisch
ich habe echt
Schnauze voll jetzt amerikanisch
ganz neue Lieferung ist da das heißt wir
können direkt die Tour fahren und alle
weiteren Bestellungen sind auch versorgt
weiter geht's
[Applaus]
danke
es geht los ich möchte ein paar Müttern
eine Freude bereit
leider keine Mutter erwischt
[Musik]
vielen Dank
alles Gute zum Muttertag noch eine
Mutter glücklich gemacht
ja alles Gute zum Geburtstag
[Musik]
ein großer Strauß und eine Person die
einfach nur ein Wein bestellt hat
[Musik]
nein 14 € mittlerer Straße der letzte
mittlere und der letzte große ja let's
go Digger letzte Tür ja
Nummer eins dann hier
[Musik]
hey hey hey hey
oh mein Gott okay dann lass uns den
Scheiß Shop schließen das hier ist unser
Trinkgeld so viel sei schon mal gesagt
das ist schon einiges wir schließen den
Shop der Shop ist zu alle orders sind
dann diese beiden Rotweinflaschen sind
übrig geblieben eine weißweinflasche und
vier von den kleinen Strolch die am
günstigsten sind die am wenigsten Umsatz
gemacht hätten in dem wenigsten Gewinn
gebracht hätten und das beste Rotwein
und Weißwein bringe ich einfach wieder
zurück weil ich habe die Rechnung und
jetzt heißt es in die Abrechnung wie
viel Umsatz wie viel Gewinn haben wir
innerhalb von zwei Tagen mit einem
Blumenshop über Muttertag gemacht let's
go was soll ich sagen es hat
geisteskrank funktioniert Samstag 538 €
Umsatz über Volt 50 € in Haus durch die
zwei Personen die einfach hier rein
kamen und vor Ort die Blumen in bar
gekauft haben Sonntag 554 € Umsatz und
insgesamt 15 € und 50 Cent Trinkgeld das
macht insgesamt ein Umsatz von
1.157 Euro und 50 Cent das muss man sich
mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen ich
habe keine Kunden ich habe keine
Laufkundschaft gehabt ich hatte keine
Bewertung auf meinem Shop und trotz
alledem konnten wir über 1.100 Euro
Umsatz machen Umsatz schön und gut aber
wie viel Gewinn haben wir gemacht leider
kann ich euch die Kosten nicht genau
aufschlüsseln weil ich von dem
blumengroßhandel darum gebeten wurde die
Kosten nicht zu zeigen das ist einfach
kein Einzelhandel man kann die Preise da
nicht einfach zeigen die sind nicht für
jeden zugänglich der ist eben nur
verhändler und das machen wir natürlich
wir dürfen ja auch dort Film also vielen
Dank noch mal an den blumengroßhandel
dass wir dort Filmen dürfen insgesamt an
Kosten hatten wir aber 374 € und 52 €.
sich zusammensetzen aus Blumen den
Karten die wir gedruckt haben Wein Gold
Kosten und Sprit für den Roller
insgesamt macht das einen Gewinn von 800
9 € und 98 Cent das richtig ja also es
ist wirklich geisteskrank und ich bin
schon am überlegen wie ich dieses System
weiter ausreizen kann dazu aber mehr in
den nächsten Folgen wenn euch diese
Folge gefallen hat lasst mir gerne ein
Like da vergessen nicht den Kanal zu
abonnieren und dann sehen wir uns in den
nächsten Tagen wieder macht's gut